Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui? A part boire du café.
On va mettre des vampires à poils en plein soleil mon pote.
Eh ouai! Twilight RPZ!
Bienvenue sur Akiba Strip undead & undressed.
*il n'arrive pas à le dire*
Les bilingues ont les oreilles qui saignent actuellement.
Je vais pas vous spoil.
Mais c'est un jeu  très, très, bien foutu! Dans lequel, on va devoir défoncer
Une meute de vampires vilains.
Qui veulent nuire à Tokyo.
On va s'appeler déshabillator voilà
Pour faire un nom un peu flippant, juste tu prends un verbe et tu rajoute "tor" à la fin.
On est setup completement et on y va.
Akihabara. Akiba' pour faire court.
Cette ville  aura tout vu...
Non vas-y... *rires*
J'ai tenté mais, en gros l'histoire...
Ça dit, que le Japon a traversé des époques difficiles nananinanana...
Et aujourd'hui c'est encore une époque de fils de p***, parce qu'il y a des vampires...
Qui veulent tuer des gens. Voilà.
Oh le déshabillator se réveille.Attention. Chut!
Ne le dérangez pas.
Mmh... C'est déjà le matin?
Bien bien bien, on dirait que tu t'es finalement réveillé.
Oh mon dieu!
Le méchant trop stylé au costard rose
et à la coupe un peu... effarouchée !!
Tu viens de passer l'examen de compatibilité.
Et tu es maintenant pret à commencer ta nouvelle vie.
En tant que Synthister.
Rien de religieux dans tout ça.
Je suis attaché à une table. Moi le grand déshabillator qui déshabille les gens dans la rue.
J'étais entrain  de faire un entretien d'embauche pour devenir journaliste
et c'est parti en steak!
wooh wo wo!  Restes calme hein! Pas comme mes cheveux!
Eux ils sont déchainés...
Tu nous as vendu ton âme ton essence
à nous Master Zenya!
Il y a un intrus dans le building.
Je  arhh... *musique romantique*
*musique romantique*
Épouse-moi!!
Qui est elle ? Qui est elle avec son parapluie divin ?
et sa beauté divine!
Suis-moi, on s'en va d'ici...
Ok! je te suis meuf.
Eh rattrapez le fils de p*te
Voila! Ça en japonais, ça voulez vraiment dire: "attrapez-les, ces fils de p**es!"
Oh, on va se battre, oh p*tains, oooh!
eh! t'es mort fils de p*te...
euh euh euh dans la tête ! Tu ne sais pas qui je suis!
Mec, j'ai fait un an de karaté , j'ai fait des katas mon gars et je sais  parfaitement comment  te retirer ton pantalon.
Hop là! Voila, énorme patate!  One punch mon gars c'est nous!
Ok! C'était très bien, tu es plus fort que je ne l'imaginais!
Bah oui .. bah oui, bah oui!
On se combat , ohh !! dos-à-dos comme dans les films!
Comme dans Angelina et Brad Pitt.
Non, ça c'est les acteurs c'est pas le nom du film on s'en fou...
Comment osez-vous ,  oh non! il a tapé mon ami
ahhh! On s'est interposé entre le coup et la femme
Y-a t'il une meilleure technique pour séduire une femme?  non!
"Tu m'as protégé?!" ouais bon voilà, j'ai pas fait exprès.
Ne les laissez pas s'échapper! Ok j'y vais, reste bien derrière moi!
Je te suis Senpai , c'est vraiment notre Senpai la meuf gère
Je crois qu'on les a semés
Tu es blessé...
C'est quand tu m'as protégé n'est-ce pas?
On aurait dit que tu contrôlais la chose mais en fait, pas du tout!
T'es une énorme m*rde!
*rire*...
Tu sais la grosse p*te!
Bon, je crois qu'on a pas d'autres choix!
Je vais partager un peu de mon sang avec toi.
DAMN IT!!!
Attends, attends, tu es de quel groupe sanguin ?
Tu es de quel groupe sanguin ? Tu es O+, A+, B, B-...
Attends, attends, attends
Si ce n'est pas compatible, tu vas me tuer en fait.
Cela va te sauver mais pendant quelques jours tu vas beaucoup souffrir
Bon écoute...
Tu sais, quand je regarde tes beaux yeux avec ce sang comme ça au coin des lèvres.
J'ai l'impression que ton père est un voleur et qu'il a volé toutes les étoiles du ciel pour te le mettre dans les yeux.
Pour te les mettre dans les yeux, pardon
Parce que j'ai arrêté l'école en sixième
Si tu veux saisir cette chance s'il te plait, bois mon sang.
*Boit dans un verre*
Ah ! C'est du A+ ! On est sur du A+ !
Hoooo! DAMN IT !
Attends tous les vampires sont pas comme ça hein.
On aurait pu tomber par exemple sur ça.
*musique "trash"*
Eh ouais, mon gars t'aurais était déçu!
On dirait que ça a prit
Putain on dirait qu'on parle de pêche quoi :
"Haa ça a prit"
Je suis un chasseur et mon devoir est de chasser ces monstres
Les "Synthisers"
Ta vie n'est plus en danger "déshabillator" mais tu es toujours faible
Et tu es très très vulnérable au soleil.
OK, VAMOS !
Et ailleurs qu'a la playa! Si tu vois ce que je veux dire
On veut pas crâmer
Mais attends, on est en plein soleil là!
Mais attends...
Mais Edward, dans Twilight il fait ça il est mort!
Oh mon dieu... on est totalement ... Hé mais attend
Mais nan! Mais meccc !
Vous, vous souvenez de notre dernière vidéo au Japon?
Y'avait mon frère qui était là, et moi je me filmais devant ce SEGA là
C'est là dedans qu'on s'est affronté a Tekken!
Et que j'ai battu Florent Hauchard bien-sûr et qu'il a ragé
Mais nan, c'est génial ! Et le sex-shop
Où, l'on a acheté Jackie Chan ici présent.
Ah non, je suis con je l'ai pas acheté au sex-shop Jackie Chan.
N'importe quoi je confond tout...
Jackie Chan, on l'a acheté dans une petite rue là bas à droite.
Mais le sex-shop là,  où il y a tout les trucs hyper glauques.
C'est ce bâtiment là, juste là mec!
Putain, ils ont vraiment reproduit à "Kebra"
Oh, je suis "hypé par ce jeux"
Bon. Allez! On a un objectif à.. à atteindre.
On a des vampires à foutre à poil, c'est pas tout mais bon....
Comment tu te sens ? ça va bien,bien.
Les mecs qui nous ont attaqués hier n’abandonnerons pas si facilement!
M*** ILs SONT LA!
Quoi ? Déjà ?
DAMN IT!
C'est elle ! On l'a retrouvé !
P*tain ! M*rde, ils n'auraient pas pu envoyer des filles ?
*rires*
J'avoue c'est vrai !
Leur sexe ne nous concerne pas.
Oh, elle l'a mal prit Shizuku.
C'est bon c'est une petite blague de beauf, ça va, détends toi...
Allez ! C'est parti ! On va les défoncer, mec !
Hop la!
Oh il a fait une esquive mon gars!
Tiens, tiens, tiens, tiens !
Oh les combos qu'on lui met !
Les Synthisters ont un corps très résistant...
...donc les blessures physiques ne suffiront pas à les vaincre.
Je vais te montrer ce qui pourra les battre
Premièrement choisis un vêtement spécifique
Par exemple son bandana
Ou alors la veste en attaquant le corps
Ou alors le pantalon en attaquant le pantalon
Ok petit sondage là
Et voilà 100% des gens ont voté pour le pantalon
*rires*
Ok donc le but ça va être d’abîmer les vêtements des mecs
Et ensuite quand ils seront suffisamment abîmer ont pourra les retirer
Genre là du coup...
AH ! Mais nan mais laisse moi te retirer ton pantalon pourquoi tu veux pas je comprends pas
Moi un mec viens dans la rue pour me retirer mon pantalon j’accepte j'dis " Vas y mets toi bien frère !"
Bon aller là, c'est bon là...
OOOOH IL A UN VIEUX SLIP DE MAMAN, ALORS !!
Ok la veste...?
Et hop la
Alors ? On est nu comme un ver de terre ?
Naaaan... Son corps s'est dissout...
Oh lala...
Attends, attends... Je sens le truc venir où genre à un moment le boss ce sera des meufs ultra sexy tu sais, comme par hasard...
Et hop la !
Oh le p'tit caleçon bleu
On est sur du bleu. C'est pas mal très bon choix !
Aller viens là, viens là, viens là
Cette petite veste là...
Plus que le bandana...
Hop la !
Je pense qu'on est en sécurité pour le moment
N'oublies pas ce que tu as apprit aujourd'hui
Ok maîtresse pardon
*rote*
Ok maintenant qu'on a battu des bandits
Je suis en train de la ramener à mon QG qui est un bar gaming
P*tain on se croirait vraiment au Japon mec c'est tellement bien
Oh lalalala !
Bienvenu au Freedom Fighter Base MOGRA
Déshabilator ! Ça fait trois jours qu'on t'a pas vu !
Eh, calmez vous ! Je sais que je vous ai manqué mais fermez la p*tain
J'ai mit à poil des gens sur la voie publique...
Hein ! Je devrai être en prison à l'heure qu'il est...
Bon les amis après une longue discussion avec tous ces gens
En gros c'est mon QG c'est mon terre terre j'peux partir en mission avec...euh... la personne de mon choix
Par exemple avec Yuto, avec Kaito...
Avec Kati
Ou avec Shizuku
Celle pour qui on a un faible
Puisqu’elle a un parapluie et... franchement euh
Ça montre qu'elle est prévoyante et qu'elle peut faire face à des situations imprevues
Comme quand il pleut par exemple